let me ask you first let me ask you
about Teresa Halbach Oh Oh Teresa halt
halt back out uh the lady at killed did
did you it was that a continuous do you
kill her is that a confession
all right glad to be back we actually um
we had some complications we were trying
to get I've never called anyone in
prison before so I don't not look so I
thought they had to call us well
hopefully I don't know it looks like
we're not going to have Steven Avery on
the show which is obviously a big
actually it's up there now what are we
on hello you have a collect call from
Steven Avery Durr will you accept the
charges
oh yes yeah we will um I guess mr. Avery
are you there yeah yeah yeah okay so
this is Steven Avery so this is I guess
how often are you how're you doing these
interviews and do they all have to be
done collect oh I don't do all the
interviews over the phone too often
they're but you know since this thing
has been on the the TV I I've been doing
a lot yeah okay um so I imagine it's
been pretty pretty busy for you well let
me ask you first let me ask you about
Teresa Halbach Oh Oh Teresa halt halt
back out of the lady at killed did did
you it was that a continuous do you kill
her is that a confession no no no I'm
sorry about that there I did not I did
not mean that there I'm sorry so you
didn't kill Teresa Halbach uh you know
no I wouldn't say that all right um okay
I'm a little confused what we'll move
back to that so here's something I do
want to ask you did you feel as though
that the Netflix documentary was an
accurate portrayal because some of the
prosecution they've said that they left
out some key evidence oh yeah I was
there for all of it and you know I
they presented my story very well very
at all I think it I think it made me
look good you know and whatnot
right well I definitely think it was
favorable let me ask you this we just
talked about this before you came on the
cat what happened with the cat oh well
you know one day I was out partying with
my friends and uh in all this cat I
don't like cats that much and who is no
wonderful I I put a little bit of uh
gasoline on it on the cat yeah I throw
it in a fire just like I did Teresa okay
see that sounds a lot like a confession
oh no I said that you let Teresa on fire
Oh see see there you're you're just
you're just painting me like the media
okay uh you know poor people always lose
with you well I don't know I'm not
necessarily rich or the media I don't
know that that's a fair accusation you
you just said that you let a cat on fire
as you did Teresa yeah you're on your
fancy studio okay
we can't all have that okay um what do
you think about the prosecutor there's
been a lot of talk about mr. Kratz all
that that Ken that Ken Kratz that guy's
a pervert if I've ever seen one
he's a pervert but what about whoa yeah
but what about you and all your you know
your charges of public masturbation and
we're revealing yourself oh you know
that that's all taken out of context you
know if yeah you don't add you don't you
don't do it every now and then it's got
nowhere to go so what's the context in
which public masturbation would be
appropriate Steven Avery well what am I
supposed to do I don't think that's a
legal defense I think you're better I
think you're presented better when
lawyers are present no no okay I I had
very good lawyers but the problem was
the corruption you know right listen
there's no doubt that there was
corruption in the trial mr. Avery I
don't doubt that for a second um but it
seems it seems I mean okay there are
some things we've talked about that
we're not presented for example at the
DNA
on the bullet came no doubt from your
gun that there was non blood DNA
evidence under the hood of the car which
they couldn't have had from the vial so
all those things we know weren't
presented well firstly why do you think
they weren't presented in the film well
you know I think I think somebody wanted
to put me in there and you know I think
that you know the filmmakers you know
they knew that you know and you know I
think you know they they probably
thought that you know people would you
know you know want me to get out you
know ya know well I guess you don't know
okay so those are things that are
concrete that we can observe now there
were some pretty serious allegations
from Brandon da see your nephew where he
said that you hadn't molested him oh
okay there uh you know you know what's a
little bit of fooling around between
family okay so but he does it well
depends on what you're talking about
everybody does it not everybody molest
family well you know you'll say
molestation I say you know fun okay what
kind of horsing around was going on I
mean we're on radio so we have to be
careful but like what you're just
talking about wrestling roughhousing was
there I mean yeah you know a little bit
of that and a little bit of touching
here a little bit of touching dare it
does touching include does touching
include cuz he alleged we have it here
in his definitely alleged that you
touched his nether his parts his private
parts oh yeah
so you said you did oh yeah uh several
times and you think that's just normal
horseplay why he touched me I touch him
I touch him first though but you know
well I'd listen mr. Avery I don't know
if that's illegal that's not that's ill
uncle okay you might okay you might want
to refrain from that in the future and I
don't know if this could be admissible
well you know I I've been in prison all
my life
sometimes I'm entitled to a little
fun now and then you know what I mean
there no I don't know I think I think I
understand where your have you tried
putt-putt putt-putt golf
that'd be a good outlet you have any
putt-putt played up there in minutes
walk county that some sometimes we play
it on the lot there with the cars okay
um we have to go here bedroom - oh God
okay listen we have to go here let me
ask you how do you think this interview
went well I think you know people can
listen and date just like the movie they
can draw their own you know opinions yes
done you know you know yeah yeah you
know what I mean there yeah okay I know
you mean we're going to go to a break
here thanks mr. Avery we'll have you
back on soon ladder with Crowder stay
tuned we're going to get some legal
letters hey if you like this video
subscribe by clicking my face or this
button or watch one of these other
videos if you're offended you should
leave